[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu einem turbulenten
nachrichten tag wo die zähne ist auch
dabei für den sport hallo wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
armin laschet will vorerst weitermachen
der cdu chef will einen personellen
neuanfang gestalten und deutet auch die
möglichkeit seines rückzugs an
auf den weg zur ampel nach ihrem ersten
treffen zu dritt wollen spd grüne und
fdp ihre sondierungen fortsetzen
und verwirrung um die impfquote offenbar
sind mehr menschen in deutschland gegen
korona geimpft als angenommen wie viele
genau wissen nicht mal experten
eigentlich war heute die ganze
politische aufmerksamkeit auf das erste
dreiertreffen zwischen spd grünen und
fdp gerichtet doch dann überraschte cdu
chef armin laschet mit einer
pressekonferenz vor einer halben stunde
ziel bleibe ein bündnis von union grünen
und fdp sagte er und deutete an dass er
sich dafür auch wenn nötig vom
parteivorsitz zurückziehen würde mathis
feldhoff aus berlin
es ist wohl der versuch sich ein letztes
stück würde zu erhalten am frühen abend
erklärt armin laschet seine bereitschaft
den weg freizumachen um jamaika noch zu
retten ich habe bereits in den
gesprächen deutlich gemacht an der
person wird es nicht scheitern
und das habe ich heute auch der fraktion
berichtet es geht nicht um die person
armin laschet es geht um das projekt für
das land noch am wahlabend hatte sich
der parteichef der cdu ganz anders
angehört der gemeinsame auftritt der
parteiführung sollte eine einheit zeigen
wie es längst nicht mehr gab und
bundeskanzler wird der dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames programm für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
doch als markus söder gestern jamaika
endgültig eine absage erteilt läuft die
politische uhr für armin laschet ab
plötzlich klingt söder schon gestern wie
ein nach ist jetzt auch die aufgabe als
union sich neben der natürlich offenheit
den gesprächen geführt haben jetzt auf
dauer auch die realitäten anzuerkennen
die sich aus diesen entscheidungen
ergeben laschets kandidatur stand von
anfang an unter einem schlechten stern
der machtkampf mit söder eine
zerstrittene fraktion gescheitert ist
der rheinländer vor allem an den eigenen
leuten wir haben zuletzt in der
öffentlichkeit eher das bild einer
abbruch kolonne abgegeben als einer
partei die lust auf zukunftsgestaltung
hat so der vize chef der cdu
arbeitnehmer
auch wenn seinen rückzug noch nicht ganz
vollzogen ist wenn er den übergang noch
moderieren will das rennen um die
nachfolge hat heute begonnen
fragen wir wieder theo koll in berlin
was bedeutet das jetzt armin laschet
geht aber noch nicht gleich ja so könnte
es verstanden werden mit seinem großen
armin laschet hält die reste option
einer möglichen jamaika regierung für
viel zu wichtig als dass es an ihm
scheitern dürfe wenn er als hürde für
jamaika empfunden werde dann wolle er
nicht im wege stehen aber im
umkehrschluss heißt das auch er könnte
auch weiter für jamaika zur verfügung
stehen insgesamt war es eine zweiteilige
botschaft in der zweite teil bezog sich
auf die neuaufstellung der cdu wir
erleben ja gerade eine verdeckte
feldschlacht in der union und armin
laschet will die zunehmend geforderte
neuaufstellung der cdu moderieren dh es
soll beispielsweise eine
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz geben und
einen parteitag das heißt er will diesen
prozess der veränderung führen und das
könne auch die übergabe der
führungsfunktion beinhalten so wie er
das in nordrhein westfalen ja gerade
gemacht hat das heißt erhält jamaika
weiter für möglich und er hat gerade den
verzicht auf den cdu vorsitz angedeutet
engagieren theo koll aus berlin
das ändert auch die gemengelage für spd
grüne und fdp sieben stunden hat das
erste treffen ihrer sondierungsteams
gedauert die roten linien waren klar bei
der spd hat sich kanzlerkandidat olaf
scholz festgelegt 12 euro mindestlohn
müssen es schon sein annalena baerbock
betont für die grünen ohne einen
wirksamen klimaschutz wird keinen
koalitionsvertrag geben und fdp chef
christian lindner sagte die liberalen
stehen zu ihrem versprechen keine
steuererhöhungen thomas reichert
berichtet es hat lange gedauert länger
als gedacht kurz nach 18 uhr treten die
generalsekretäre mit einer stunde
verspätung vor die presse von sehr guten
verhandlungen ist die rede und von
diesem vorsatz dass man mit einem
politischen stil jetzt in die gespräche
reingeht der nicht von gewinnern und
verlierern geprägt ist sondern der dafür
sorgt dass am ende alle parteien eine
regierung gemeinsam bilden alle parteien
auch ihre schwerpunkte setzen können die
fdp hat den weitesten weg in ein
ampelbündnis
ein bisschen nervennahrung kann da schon
helfen die fdp fordert verständnis für
die unterschiede und bekommt es offenbar
umso wichtiger war es für uns in einem
dreier gespräch
herauszufinden ob es die bereitschaft
gibt auch größere hürden gemeinsam zu
nehmen
das haben wir heute gesehen und
dementsprechend unserem präsidium die
vertiefte sondierung empfohlen an dem
das präsidium einstimmig zustimmen die
fdp lässt sich ein auf die ampel
rechtzeitig vor den grünen kommt am
morgen greenpeace mit dem klima fahrrad
und drückt den grünen unter händlern
noch ein paar forderungen in die hand
eine mahnung der kernklientel aber
erstmal kein stimmungskiller
man kann
vertraulich und vertrauensvoll
miteinander reden über alle themen
natürlich das ja auch klar ist da noch
ein ganzes stück des weges zu gehen aber
ich glaube lösung lassen sich finden am
nächsten montag soll es mit den
vertieften sondierungen dann losgehen
für die ampel scheint es irgendwie
aufwärts zu gehen
zum thema corona die ständige
impfkommission empfiehlt jetzt eine
auffrischung
auffrischimpfung für alle über 70
jährigen die empfehlung gilt darüber
hinaus für medizinisches personal und
für menschen die in altenheimen leben
oder arbeiten
eine wichtige frage kam heute auf sind
möglicherweise viel mehr menschen in
deutschland gegen korona geimpft als
angenommen so seien am nachmittag die
offiziellen zahlen aus 79,1 prozent der
erwachsenen haben mindestens eine
impfdosis bekommen
75,6 prozent sind vollständig geimpft
eine umfrage des robert koch instituts
allerdings lässt aufhorchen
demnach liegt die impfquote unter
erwachsenen merklich höher als von den
ämtern erfasst andrea maurer
maske draußen tragen geht es nach dem
gesundheitsminister fällt diese
vorschrift im kampf gegen korona schon
bald weg wie jetzt bekannt wurde sind
womöglich mehr menschen durch impfung
geschützt als von der melde- statistik
erfasst befragung des rk ii gehen davon
aus dass eine unterschätzung von bis zu
5 prozentpunkten für den anteil
mindestens einmal geimpfter
beziehungsweise vollständig geimpfter
angenommen werden kann
der minister der seine politik immer
auch mit impfquoten begründet hat
versucht eine erklärung
die diskrepanz zwischen gemeldeten
impfungen und dem was jetzt das
robert-koch-institut auch in umfragen
festgestellt hat ergibt sich eben
dadurch dass möglicherweise manche
impfungen nicht gemeldet worden sind bis
zu fünf prozent mehr geimpft
bürgerinnen und bürger in deutschland
das ist ein echter unterschied und den
müssen und wollen wir natürlich jetzt
auch mit einbeziehen in unsere
überlegung 84 prozent der erwachsenen
womöglich vollständig geimpft das sei
eine gute nachricht so sparen sie mache
weitere beschränkungen unnötig andere
warnen wir sind vor schwierigen wochen
und es kann durchaus sein dass wir in
wenigen wochen in der mittleren
altersgruppe schwere verläufe haben und
bei den etwas älteren sogar also impf
durchbrüche haben somit an entwarnung
sehe ich noch nicht kritik an den rk ii
befragungen kommt von patienten schützen
was uns sorgen macht das jetzt befragung
also umfragewerte die realität abbilden
wollen da weiß ja jeder dass ein
befragter in der regel sozial
erwünschtes verhalten
dokumentiert das hat aber nichts mit
fakten zu tun frischs befürchtungen dass
sparen eine höhere impfquote als erfolg
der impfkampagne verkündet könnte die
impfbereitschaft unentschlossener weiter
senken
wie es dazu kommen konnte dass das
robert-koch-institut verschiedene
impfquoten meldet können sie auch in
unserer zdf heute app nachlesen dort
wird erklärt welche schwächen die
berechnungsmethoden haben
österreichs bundeskanzler kurz gerät
zunehmend unter druck die razzia im
bundeskanzleramt gestern hat ein
politisches beben ausgelöst kurz und
seinem team wird schwere korruption
vorgeworfen der 35 jährige weist alle
schuld von sich doch der grüne
koalitionspartner geht auf distanz und
die opposition sagt kurths beschädige
den ruf österreichs wenn er im amt
bleibt aus wien britta hilpert die
polizei rüstet sich am morgen für
aufregung rund um den sitz von kanzler
und präsident zu recht denn österreichs
regierung von vp und grünen
der schwebe die vorwürfe gegen die
spitze der bvb wiegen schwer und deshalb
geht es jetzt um stabilität und ordnung
die grünen stellen die
handlungsfähigkeit der regierung in
frage denn die staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt gegen kurz und sein umfeld
artikel und umfragen der zeitung
österreich sollen bestellt und bezahlt
worden seien verschleiert über das
finanzministerium also mit stonn erkennt
diese artikel und umfragen sollen den
aufstieg von kurz zum parteivorsitzenden
und kanzler begünstigt haben er kann
diese funktion und dieses amt jetzt
nicht mehr ausführen ohne dass es großen
schaden nimmt kanzler kurz betont die
unschuldsvermutung er will
weiterregieren wenn man ihn lässt wenn
die grünen also nicht mehr diese
zusammenhang jetzt fortsetzen wollen und
sich andere mehrheiten im parlament
suchen wollen dann ist dies zu
akzeptieren
von selbst geht er nicht sebastian kurz
hat seinen rücktritt ausgeschlossen der
ball liegt nun im feld der grünen
koalitionspartner die haben die
handlungsfähigkeit der regierung wegen
der ermittlungen in frage gestellt
schwer vorstellbar wie sie da weiter mit
sebastian kurz regieren wollen
spätestens am dienstag kommt es zum
politischen showdown im nationalrat muss
sich kanzler kurz einem misstrauensvotum
stellen
zwischen polen und der eu bahnt sich ein
großer konflikt an das polnische
verfassungsgericht ging heute auf
konfrontation zur gesetzgebung der
europäischen union begleitet von
protesten entschieden die richter vor
einer guten stunde dass einige gesetze
der eu im widerspruch zur polnischen
verfassung stehen das verfahren war von
der rechtskonservativen polnischen
regierung angestrengt worden
an der herz lieb in warschau welche
politische tragweite hat dieses urteil
das verfassungsgericht hat heute eine
reihe von artikeln aus eu-verträgen
aufgelistet die im widerspruch mit dem
polnischen grundgesetz stehen auch zitat
der versuch des europäischen
gerichtshofs sich in das polnische
justizsystem einzumischen stünden im
widerspruch mit der verfassung so die
richter eine eu-mitgliedschaft bedeutet
eben nicht dass man seine souveränität
abdrehte und für viele beobachter ist
das urteil heute der absolute worst case
im eu parlament in brüssel hieß es das
sei eine kampfansage
ein angriff auf einen der grundpfeiler
der eu und es mehren sich die stimmen
die befürchten dass polen damit weiter
in die isolation treibe
live aus war schon an herzlichen dank
die bundesregierung hat acht deutsche
mutmaßliche us anhängerinnen und ihre 23
kinder nach deutschland zurückgeholt
nach der ankunft in frankfurt am main
wurden drei der frauen verhaftet der
vorwurf mitgliedschaft in einer
terroristischen vereinigung
gegen zwei weitere frauen liegen
haftbefehle vor zuletzt lebten die
mütter mit ihren kindern in einem
gefangenenlager in syrien
ein starkes erdbeben hat den südwesten
pakistans erschüttert es überraschte
viele menschen im schlaf rettungskräfte
vermuten dass unter den trümmern noch
viele menschen eingeschlossen sind
bislang ist von mindestens 20 toten die
rede rund 300 menschen wurden verletzt
weitere opfer werden befürchtet weil die
rettungskräfte noch nicht in abgelegene
gebiete vordringen konnten
wieder nach deutschland jahrzehntelang
lebte josef s unbehelligt in brandenburg
an der havel jetzt steht der 100 jährige
vor gericht er soll als ss wachmann im
kz sachsenhausen beihilfe zum mord an
tausenden häftlingen geleistet haben
warum jetzt erst der prozess erst vor
wenigen jahren machte die justiz klar
auch sekretärinnen oder wachleute im kz
hatten anteil an den massenmorden für
die überlebenden ist das von enormer
bedeutung aus brandenburg katrin lindner
für den 98 jährigen überlebenden adolf
studzinski ist dieser es wichtig fünf
jahre war in sachsenhausen inhaftiert
wir haben doch alles mitgemacht was die
so befohlen haben unschuldig ist kein
netter conti das muss geklärt werden die
hunde die jährige josef es war als
junger mann im kz sachsenhausen wachmann
die anklage lautet auf beihilfe zum mord
in mehr als 3500 fällen da geht es um
die erschießung von sowjetischen
kriegsgefangenen
es geht um die ermordung von häftlingen
durch giftgas und auch um die ermordung
von häftlingen durch die schaffung und
aufrechterhaltung von lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen den turm gibt es noch von
dem die wachposten beim appell auf die
gefangenen im konzentrationslager
schauten jetzt steht erstmals einer der
wachmänner aus sachsenhausen vor gericht
16 nebenkläger treten auf überlebende
und angehörige und horn grumbach verlor
seinen vater in sachsenhausen dem sohn
fehlen heute die worte die sache geht
weiter sicher
mehr kann ich nicht sagen
die ermittler in ludwigsburg kamen josef
es im militärarchiv moskau auf die spur
stuttgart unterlagen die die rote armee
mit noch etwas vorgenommen hatte dass er
zb der pässe truppen stamm rollen pro
panelisten und da haben wir den
angeklagten gefunden für antoine
grumbach dessen vater hier starb es
dieser prozess der prozess einer späten
gerechtigkeit
nach 18 jahren geht der
literatur-nobelpreis erstmals wieder an
einen schriftsteller aus afrika abdul
rasak corona der 73-jährige schildere
kompromisslos und mitfühlen die folgen
des kolonialismus und das schicksal von
flüchtlingen in seinen werken journalist
im sansibar geboren ende der 60er jahre
floh er nach großbritannien wurde
professor im kennt den wichtigsten preis
der literatour wird mit grüner allen
menschen in afrika und seinen lesern
sie auch nicht nur da absolut und jetzt
mit fußball wieder okay mache ich weiter
die deutsche fußball-nationalmannschaft
will da anknüpfen und weiter machen wo
sie im september aufgehört hat nachdem
drei siege start in der wm-qualifikation
strebt man die nächsten erfolge am
morgen gegen rumänien und montag in nord
mazedonien
der bundestrainer plant einen erfolg
fest ein und hofft spielerisch auf
weitere fortschritte der neue chef hat
den konkurrenzkampf neu entfacht alle im
kader sind einsatzbereit in der
innenverteidigung werden niklas süle und
antonio rüdiger spielen das team will
die fans begeistern doch rumänien steht
hinten stabil sie haben die letzten drei
spiele zu null in der gruppenphase auch
gespielt das heißt wir haben eine starke
defensive eingespielte defensive und
deswegen ist einfach wichtig dass wir da
eine hohe intensität auffahrende gegner
versuchen unter druck zu setzen flick
ließ offen ob reus oder müller auf die
offensive position im mittelfeld rückt
kicken sie so schnell und direkt wie
eben beim abschlusstraining dann könnte
es ein recht flottes länder wir werden
europameister italien hat den einzug ins
finale der nations league verpasst für
die azzurri die erste niederlage seit
mehr als drei jahren
die italiener in blau verlieren in
mailand 1 2 gegen spanien fährt an
torres erzielt für die gäste beide
treffer in der ersten hälfte nach einer
gelb roten karte gegen kapitän leonardo
bonucci kurz vor der pause kommt italien
in unterzahl nur noch zum
anschlusstreffer durch leonardo
pellegrini für das team von roberto
mancini ist es die erste niederlage nach
37 spielen spanien spielt am sonntag im
finale gegen den sieger des zweiten
halbfinals belgien gegen frankreich
und der deutsche bahnrad vierer der
frauen hat em-gold gewonnen nach dem
olympiasieg in tokio gelang der erfolg
in der mannschaftsverfolgung diesmal
ohne lisa klein das quartett mit den
olympiasiegerinnen lisa brennauer
franziska bronze und mieke kröger sowie
der nachwuchsfahrerin laura süßemilch
setzte sich in der schweiz im finale
gegen den vorjahres-zweiten italien
durch
starkes quartett ja absolut das war's
hollywood boulevard das ist die adresse
für die stars der stars im film vor der
hausnummer 7 007 freute sich jetzt bond
darsteller daniel craig über seinen
persönlichen stark es mache ihn sehr
glücklich auf dem walk of fame von all
diesen legenden umgeben zu sein sein
direkter nachbar ist einer seiner
vorgänger roger moore
größtenteils ruhiges herbstwetter
verspricht gleichstand elli christian
sievers begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die dauerblockade
im osten europas und richtung russland
bleibt uns immer noch erhalten das hoch
dehnt sich sogar noch weiter aus und
bringt uns ruhiges wetter aber schauen
sie mal richtung mittelmeer da gibt es
einen tief was dort gefangen ist und
große regenmengen der balkanregion
bringen wird teilweise 300 liter auf den
quadratmeter bis freitag unwetter
vorprogrammiert schauen wir auf die
nachts da gibt es im osten nebel nach
westen lockert auf im süden kommt regen
dazu dass bei temperaturen von zehn grad
im osten und am kühlsten in den
westdeutschen mittelgebirgen um 3 grad
morgen dann viel sonne vor allem nach
osten und auch wenn sich der nebel
auflöst und zeigt sich die sonne
ansonsten in der mitte und im süden
viele wolken aber auch mal sonnenschein
bei höchsten temperaturen bis 19 grad
ganz im westen und 12 grad in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen ja die nächsten
tage gehen ruhig weiter vor allem am
wochenende haben wir es mit nebel zu tun
aber danach auch mit sonnenschein am
montag kommt vor allem im norden neuer
regen auf temperaturen insgesamt
zwischen 10 und 19 grad ein schöner
abend